as the race for the presidency heats up
we thought it would be a good idea to
send our own Raymond Arroyo onto the
streets of New York City to get the
pulse of the voters on all the
candidates and the issues that they're
focusing on ahead of 2020 any candidate
that you think on the Democratic side
should run against Trump at this point I
don't know about should none of them are
seem to be qualified seem to be able to
hold a candle to compete against him who
should run against the president wow
that's another really good question
after the first debate I think there was
there were more questions than answers
it's gonna be interesting I don't think
anyone stand a chance against Trump at
this point I think they keep getting
each other's way all right I don't think
there's this slitted solidified party I
mean no one's representing the people
they're trying to represent a small
faction what is the issue driving your
vote this election season what will you
be most looking for and at well I'm a
little scared socialism so that's going
to be a big you know take on why I vote
the way I vote and and I think the
immigration issue right now is kind of a
disaster I'm most focused on how great
the economy is right now I mean it's
doing fantastic I mean we have an
immigration problem at the border that a
lot of people seem to be denying he's
there but you know he's working on it I
think just whoever can move our country
forward I mean I think that's the big
thing on everyone's mind from economics
to all the big issues that people are
fighting about that I'm staying away
from you need to be a politician you
know that you're already you've got
you've got I like that you've got all
sides covered maybe you should run well
he won't even give me a straight answer
on that